how's the girl breaths my name is Peter
and this video was brought to you by a
new crate
I was recently in Japan did a little bit
of shopping if there's one thing I hate
doing most it's putting creams on my
face so today we're gonna put creams on
my face baby let's go alright so today
we're gonna be starting well being a cat
the instructions are in Japanese pocket
now
I can't even piss oh I hate creams I
[__] I have like cream football
[__] me I don't want to do this
oh it smell good either I never like I
look like a little baby right now
but I hate this I [__] hate this why
do people do this this is the least
disgusting one that we have by the way I
know my god
it looks like I stole the face of a cat
oh no no I feel like I'm gonna puke
it's so [__] gross happy thoughts
coming nickel Chan hell right now this
reminds me of a porno I watched once I'm
gonna leave it on for 15 minutes and
then I will see the bed actually I'll
get in hey we're back now let us see the
results baby now it's your turn
moving on to the next mask I can tell it
looks like a lubed up
not only you will have a baby face now
baby because we got the baby mask face
babies I don't know if it would look
like a baby or if you'll make my face
like a baby but either way it is a
winner let's go oh this one is fat dick
smells like you baby all right time to
be a baby baby
now we wait 15 minutes
and then 15 minutes have missed that was
time to see the results
baby baby this one which will foam up on
my face and you get to peel it off it
looks so gross it has some we need to
make silly some kind of substance let's
see if we can figure it out and we're
gonna dip this with three of these one
two three four now we scared stay steer
as we do the car you stare at all what
are we doing then stuff we stick good
give it a feel nice and moist
how does it look it's really good listen
oh my eyebrows what are you doing is it
on my eyebrows I'm gonna feel so good
how you doing I do this every day this
is how you stay on top of the game this
is how you win win win you like that
yeah
it's my treat ASMR baby now we wait
fifteen minutes
I can't move my face I feel like I am on
Botox or some [__]
I aside - oh God move okay no no no
[__] hell [__] hey let this most
disgusting [__] thing [__] this
[__] piece of [__] I feel great I
look good
for those you didn't the cat what about
having tolerance
don't you care about equality talk to me
like that again you [__] Trump
supporter get out of here
I'm gonna do the dog one Oh God this one
is disgusting is it so [__] creamy
Hey look at this I got your face porch
please give it back I feel great I love
this one this is a plus hey you this is
the most disgusting thing like look at
this [__] picture would you put that
on your face Oh what is this [__] tar
look at this [__]
it feels good this one feels nice I can
dig it
I mean biggety biggety biggety biggety
I'm scared of getting my eyebrows is I
don't want to lose my eyebrows you know
what I mean I feel great how do I look
we gotta wait 15 more minutes then his
face is hopefully gonna come off she was
only 16
I must bring the killer to justice for I
am beautify
Spa Day is all about relaxing it doesn't
matter what happens
YouTube can be hard people don't realize
what that oh yeah keep looking
wait I need to alright feel pretty
what's that
that sound
Hey look at that okay so thanks to
sponsor eagle we're going to unbox last
month's loot crate let's do it
see what's inside if you have yours
bring it in let's do it together
it'll be a bonding moment loot crate
changes its theme monthly on the 19th
now let's see what we got inside a Spock
t-shirt now I don't have to be naked
anymore skin color my favorite color
looks good
so a pristine is gonna be quest so don't
remember to check that out here we got
them a VP figure so this is random what
we're gonna get hey hey look at Papa
bliss we got Harley Quinn and loot crate
exclusive magazine that's pretty cool we
got Batman versus Superman that's a
poster is it small away whatever that's
awesome so next time we got a word gush
so it's a free download for your
smartphone okay so it's a net that's
cool I'll check it out I'll play with my
friends I have friends shut the [__] up
alright guys so next month's theme is
gonna be quest it's gonna be five
exclusive items in it from like Harry
Potter
labyrinth History Channel Vikings so if
you guys are interested in loot crate
check it out go to loot crate calm sly
spirits and there the code pairs you get
10% out I really recommend it it's like
getting a Santa Claus to your mailbox
every month it's cool
now let's peel this [__] thing up how
I can't
oh it hurts
how oh my god oh that's disgusting
I'm crying it's like a peeling tape off
your [__] face I'm gonna actually
crying [__] this ah you see this is this
nothing here is there anything here it
feels so soft it's [__] amazing holy
[__] yeah
I started peeling up a giant banner on
your [__] face Oh
okay my skin feels amazing it's never
been the stuff ever
it's like silk alright so thank you so
much for watching this video leave a
like and I really appreciate it
check out Luca comm size fits into the
code Pierce percent off and I'll see
Bruce in the next one as always stay
awesome guys
the essence of cow but will it soda
let's find out Jesus Christ why is it so
hard